من جده تنضم الينا اختصاصيه التغذيه رويدا
ادريس دكتوره رويدا مساء الخير حياك الله
معي من الرياض كل عام وانت بخير رمضان
كريم يسعد مساك وانتم بخير ان شاء الله يا
رب خلينا نسال اولا لاي مدى الصيام شهر
رمضان فرصه لانقاص الوزن فرصه
لاكمال من بدا اي حميه غذائيه كانت على
مدار السنه وكانت ايضا حتى قبل شهر رمضان
ولا هذا الامر صعب يا دكتوره بسبب تنوع
الموائد الكبير واحتوائها على كثير من
الاغذيه الصحيه وغير الصحيه
مشاهدين العربيه بخير طبعا شهر رمضان هو
افضل شهر في السنه لانقاص الوزن يعني هو
البدايه الصحيحه اللي ممكن نعمل اعاده
تشغيل لجسمها لجسمنا من خلال الشهر الكريم
اننا نصحح عادات غذائيه
واننا نفقد الدهون المخزنه في جسمنا
بنتيجه الشهور السابقه كلها طبعا كونه
احنا دائما بحس انه في تضخيم لموضوع موائد
رمضان
انها غنيه في اشياء كثيره هي سبحان الله
انت لو حطيت ثلاثه اصناف
تلاقيها عبت السفره لانه شهر رمضان شهر
كريم
والواحد يحس اي حاجه فيها بركه اي حاجه
بيعملها فيها بركه
والقصه دكتور رويدا انه انت عندك ساعات
صيام طويله وعندك ايضا ساعات افطار فهذه
ساعات الافطار يعني ما نبغى نقول اكثر
اكثر الناس
الاختيارات اللي بياكلوها احنا ممكن انه
تكون خياراتنا اشياء صحيه ومفيده وتساعدنا
لليوم الثاني يعني انه نكمل صيامنا بصحه
وعافيه لكن اذا كانت الاختيارات اللي احنا
حضرتك عمال تقول عنها هي من الحلويات
والمقليات
المحمر والمشمر زي ما يقولوا طبعا اكيد
حيزيد الوزن لكن احنا بنتكلم على الشيء
اللي يفترض انه ناتج عن الوعي الصحي اللي
صار في مجتمعنا الحمد لله دكتور بمجرد ما
يدخل شهر رمضان الكثير من الناس يتجه الى
البحث عن افضل رجيم في رمضان افضل حميه في
رمضان
واكيد الناس حتتجه الى الى الى الى محركات
البحث ويبدا يبحث عن افضل رجيم او كيف
انقص الوزن في رمضان وتطلع الاعلانات
الكثيره اخسر 30 كيلو في رمضان 20 كيلو
واتبع هذه الحميه الغذائيه ويعطيك جدول
منتظم واشيل المفروض انت تاكل وايش
المفروض ما تاكل
يجب اتباع هذه النظم الغذائيه ولا هذه فقط
لمجرد تسويق وخلينا نقول بالعمي يعني ضحك
على الناس
هي التسويقيه بحته
انه بيخرجوا من رمضان او بيخرجوا نتيجه
اتباع الاشياء الخاطئه او الحميات الخاطئه
بخرجوا بزياده في الوزن وانا دائما اقول
لو نظرنا الى المنحنى حق السمنه خلال
الاعوام السابقه للان حنلاقي بارتفاع وليس
بانخفاض فلو فعلا في هذه الاشياء اللي
ذكرتها انها تنزل الوزن 30 كيلو وعشرين
كيلو وعشره كيلو في الشهر فكلها اشياء ما
هي صحيحه والنزول الوزن السريع اكيد حاله
مرضيه غير صحيه
فالنزول الطبيعي يكون في الشهر اربعه كيلو
على الكثير سته كيلو يعني هذا بالاكثر
خليني اسال بما انك اختصاصيه دكتور دكتوره
واخيرا يعني ما هو افضل رجيم يتناسب مع
شهر رمضان
اللي هي الصيام المتقطع او الوجبه الواحده
هذا بيكون افضل انواع الحميات لانه
بيساعدك الوقت انه انت اساسا صيام فيساعدك
انك تاخذ وجبه واحده تكون متكامله وباقي
الوقت لغايه وقت السحور حيكون عندك
الزبادي والخضروات السلطات الملوخيار
والاشياء هذه والسوائل طبعا شيء اساسي
ولكن نبعد عن السوائل الغنيه بالسكريات
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من جده اختصاصيه التغذيه
دكتوره رويدا ادريس شكرا جزيلا لك